The western part of the world is made up of many different ethnicities and cultures,...
...but as far as manners are concerned, there is one thing in common:...
...it is the custom that is expected of men, to treat women well.
For example, you can easily find men...
...who would help women who carry heavy things,...
...even if they don't know each other.
I learned in school...
...that the treatment of women in a gentlemanly manner like that...
...is based on the concept of chivalry,...
...which originated in Western Europe.
Right, and another thing is, that men would open doors for women.
I saw a lot of men who would open doors for women at the mall,...
...or as they get in the car.
Oh, and in addition to that, men would give up their seats for women in the subway.
In Korea, we are taught to stand up from our seats for elderly people.
But in the United States, I noticed that men usually do not take empty seats...
...if there are women standing,...
...no matter how old they are.
I like that practice, I guess partly because I am a woman.
It's good to see that women are treated nicely and respectfully.